calling for freedom from the campus of
their University and Iranian city of
Saint John
across the country universities and
schools have become sites of mass
protests many of them led by female
students
reports of plaincloth's police being
deployed to campuses have stirred
concerns of a further lethal Crackdown
against young peaceful protesters
president Ibrahim bricey admitted to
what he called certain shortcomings in
the country but the Iranian leader still
stuck to the official line
the enemy is aiming to reduce our social
capital it wants the people to lose hope
and it wants to exaggerate our
weaknesses and shortcomings we don't
deny weaknesses and shortcomings
Verizon echoed claims made earlier by
Iran's supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei he had accused enemies of Iran
the U.S and Israel a fueling protest to
destabilize the country Khamenei has
refused to acknowledge widespread
opposition to his religious government
activists say he is simply trying to
silence internal descent
the current government in Iran has built
the power on lies and on killing people
of course they should stop the violence
they should stop killing people they
should stop imprisoning people and they
should listen to people people say it
clearly all over the country since so
many decades they don't want a religious
government
despite the violent suppression that has
so far killed dozens protests have shown
no signs of dying down
now where president Ibrahim raisi has
called for National unity in the face of
ongoing anti-government protests in the
country ricey blamed the unrest on the
U.S and Israel echoing Commons by Iran's
supreme leader anti-government
demonstrations continue to spread to
universities and high schools across
Iran the protests began after the death
of 22 year old Masa amini following her
arrest for allegedly violating the
Islamic Republic's strict dress code
meanwhile people are taking to the
streets to show their support
[Music]
[Applause]
Europeans have come out in solidarity
for women leading the fight for justice
in Iran here in Paris over the weekend
thousands rallied to support Iranians
facing a brutal regime at home
European Parliament president petsola
echoed their message paying tribute to
women who gave everything in their fight
we are with you Mark samini will be
remembered just like Hadith minu azalez
and many many others for women for life
for Liberty across party lines European
lawmakers are showing their support
it's totally unacceptable in 21st
century to accept that one woman can be
killed for defend their own rights
solidarity matters but words won't be
enough says the ep's guest of honor
French Iranian sociology Professor
azadikian I think that EU the EU should
take really measures to show the Iranian
regime that Democratic societies and
Democratic regimes are supporting the
plight of Iranian people for for
democracy and for Freedom the European
Union's top Diplomat Joseph Burrell said
the EU will continue to consider all the
options at its disposal ahead of his
speech some member states have been more
precise EU countries are preparing
action against Tehran Germany France and
others have submitted proposals for EU
sanctions against members of the Iranian
regime
this includes travel bans and acid
freezes the Iranian government has
silenced protests before and external
actions have done little to stop this
Swedish MEP Ali spakunka says the EU
should not repeat past mistakes when
ramping up pressure on Iran the most
important thing is that we are very
aware of that the sanctions risk to make
the Iranian people suffer even more so
we need to make sure that the sanctions
in the toolbox are pointed at the regime
at the people responsible for the
violence The Killing at the moral police
and at those people high in power
sanctions are for the member states to
decide but the majority in Parliament
seem determined to send a strong signal
to help make this happen
like the French and about this we can
now speak to seba Shakib she's an
Iranian filmmaker writer and political
activist and joins us from Italy hello
thanks for joining us on DW
um EU lawmaker is underlining their
their solidarity with the protesters
targeted sanctions are now on the table
is that enough
no it's not enough good evening
the EU has a very big interest for
instance and this is just one example in
Iran not to become a nuclear power
[Music]
um
if the U is really interested in Iran
not having nuclear weapons they should
stop talking to these people and they
should talk to people who want democracy
who want freedom who want equal rights
in Iran and you can be sure that Iran
will not have nuclear power people who
Now kill their own people in Iran the
government the representatives of the
government have daughters in the in in
in the U.S in Europe in Germany in Italy
they study they are models they are
wearing no hijab they are wearing modern
clothes they show skin they show hair
why can these people still be outside
and live their lives while their fathers
are killing Daughters of other people in
Iran there are so many measurements we
can close embassies we can get the
ambassadors and the consuls to not to be
able to do the work that they are doing
in all the countries in the world so
many things can be done sanction is not
the only and not the best solution
right Crackdown has been Fierce on the
protest but those out on the streets are
not deterred where does that resilience
and Defiance come from
part of it is because it was just one
drop too many a girl 22 years old a
Kurdish Girl Gina known as uh amini
killed because she's showing a little
bit of hair I mean how dangerous is hair
that you have to kill a person for that
it was just that one drop that was too
many and then of course a lot of the
power comes from the fact that so many
women and girls take the streets and
they are leading the demonstrations and
I think it's worldwide there is nothing
there has never been anything like this
and another factor that supports the
women is indeed the solidarity from
outside programs like your yours for
instance not stopping to send the
message out what's happening in Iran
support the women and encourages them to
go on and risk their life and everything
it is for all intents and purposes very
remarkable what is happening in Iran and
and the courage is admirable but how
much of a threat do the protests really
pose to the country's leadership
I think everything I think everything is
possible I think this can topple the
regime in Iran if the support from the
world does not stop and the the people
in Iran have the feeling that once the
regime is total they get the help from
foreign countries and and foreign
countries will support them I think this
can go on to the end and I'm very very
very full of fear and I'm full of Hope
because both is possible nobody can say
it goes definitely this direction or
that direction thousands and thousands
of people have been killed in the past
44 years by the government
thank you so much for your time and your
view on what is happening in Iran in
your home country
thank you